[Musik]
Hallo. Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Man könnte ja meinen, ich habe schon alle Erdbeerrezepte gemacht,
die es auf dieser Welt gibt.
Aber ich habe gesehen, ich habe noch keine Erdbeervanilletorte.
Deswegen gibt es heute eine Erdbeervanilletorte
- eine relativ einfach, denn ich habe mir gedacht:
Neulich kam ja auch der Rhabarberschmandkuchen bei euch super an.
Ich glaube, ihr mögt einfach auch den Wechsel zwischen
aufwendigen und einfachen Torten.
Deswegen heute eine relativ einfache Torte mit einem
Mandelbiskuit, einer leckeren Vanillecreme und Erdbeeren.
Ich bereite jetzt erst einmal den Biskuit zu.
Den Ofen habe ich bereits auf 180°C Ober-/Unterhitze vorgeheizt
und habe jetzt hier die Zutaten. Ich verwende dafür
30 g gehobelte Mandeln, 4 Eier, 1 Prise Salz, etwas Vanilleextrakt,
1 EL Amaretto, 100 g Zucker und 100 g Mehl.
Beim Amaretto gibt es alkoholischen und alkoholfreien.
Ihr entscheidet einfach, welchen ihr nehmt.
Ihr könnt aber auch Amaretto als Öl benutzen,
also dieses Backöl / Backaroma.
Ich muss aber sagen, ich nehme es immer mal im Wechsel,
also entweder den alkoholfreien oder diese Backöle.
Was ich jetzt zuerst machen werde:
die Mandeln in dem Backring verteilen.
Die Rösten dann schön am Boden. Ganz toll!
Der Backring ist auf 20 cm eingestellt.
Den kann ich zur Seite stellen.
Heute ist übrigens mein erstes Video nach unserer Türkeireise.
Also ich bin noch nicht ganz im Flow, aber es kommt gleich.
In 3 Minuten sind wir wieder fit, oder Josh? [Josh stimmt zu]
Bei den Eiern darauf achten, dass sie zimmerwarm sind.
[Gähnt] Ohjemine. Ich bin heute echt noch müde.
Dann kommt hier das Salz hinein.
Ich glaube, man sieht es auch an meinen Augen.
Ein bisschen Vanilleextrakt, Amaretto und Zucker.
Jetzt könnt ihr die Zutaten etwa 10-15 Min. schön cremig verrühren.
Ich habe auch schon einen Basic-Teig gemacht,
also ein Biskuit Grundrezept.
Da könnt ihr euch auch noch einmal nach Biskuit-Tipps umschauen.
Jetzt mache ich noch meinen Laptop leise.
Der ist irgendwie auch noch laut.
[Küchenmaschine]
[Musik]
Guckt mal, so sollte die Masse jetzt aussehen. Richtig schön luftig.
Da siebe ich jetzt das Mehl dazu
[Musik]
und hebe es vorsichtig unter.
Jetzt hier vorsichtig hineinfüllen.
Beim Biskuit nicht so lange rühren, sondern wirklich nur unterheben
und dann kommt er direkt in den Backofen.
Ich liebe es: Wenn ich schnelle Torten zubereiten möchte,
mache ich entweder No-Bake…
Gesundheit! Jutta hat ein bisschen… [Lacht]
Entweder No-Bake oder einfach etwas mit Biskuit.
Das geht einfach schnell, ist supereinfach
und braucht vor allem nicht viele Zutaten.
Hier vorsichtig verstreichen und sofort backen.
Ich stelle den Biskuit nach dem Backen, wenn die Backzeit vorbei ist,
einfach auf ein Abkühlgitter, lasse ihn dann ein bisschen abkühlen
und löse ihn dann erst aus der Form heraus und werde dann
in der Zwischenzeit schon einmal die Vanillecreme zubereiten.
[Musik]
[Uhr]
Für die Creme nehme ich 350 g Sahne, Vanilleextrakt,
3,5 TL San-apart zum Steifschlagen, 250 g Sahnequark (40%),
50 g Puderzucker und 2,5 TL San-apart
und zum Füllen habe ich hier schon 200 g Erdbeeren vom Grün befreit.
Beim Sahneschlagen immer darauf achten,
dass die Sahne kühlschrankkalt und nicht warm ist.
Am besten eine hohe Rührschüssel wählen
und diese sollte auch kalt sein.
Also jetzt nicht direkt aus der Spülmaschine raus und verwenden,
und auch der Schneebesen sollte schön kalt sein.
Das einmal als Sahneschlag-Tipps.
Ich bin auch richtig stolz, denn neulich hat die Sarah
mit ihrer Freundin gebacken bzw. ihr Freundin wollte backen.
Dann hätte sie es fast getan, sie hätte fast den Fehler begangen
und warme Sahne in einer warm abgespülten Schüssel verrührt.
Dann hat Sarah direkt gesagt: „Nein, das muss alles kalt sein!“
Dann haben sie es schnell ins Gefrierfach gestellt
und dann steifgeschlagen.
Ins Gefrierfach!
Ich bin so stolz auf Sarah.
Perfekt, sie hat einfach zugehört und gelernt.
Voll schön. Das macht mich so stolz.
Jedenfalls habe ich hier Sahne und Vanilleextrakt.
Kurz verrühren und dann San-apart zum Steifschlagen dazugeben.
[Musik]
[Handrührgerät]
Warum spritzt es immer so? Selbst aus der Schüssel!
Ich brauche echt ein hohes Rührgefäß.
[Bling] Ah, so wie die Kochblume.
Und dann so!
[Handrührgerät]
Problem gelöst.
[Musik]
Von der steifgeschlagenen Sahne nehme ich jetzt 100 g
für die Dekoration zur Seite – für die Sahnetupfer.
Sie kommt jetzt in den Kühlschrank.
Hier gebe ich noch den Quark dazu.
Dann Puderzucker
und noch einmal San-apart, denn San-apart bindet nicht nur Sahne,
sondern auch Quark und andere Cremes.
Jetzt noch kurz unterheben.
Ich stelle sie jetzt kurz in den Kühlschrank.
Dann kann ich jetzt hier noch die Erdbeeren
in feine Scheiben schneiden.
Ihr könnt sie aber auch würfeln oder vierteln.
[Musik]
Dann geht es jetzt an die Tortenfüllung.
Dafür nehme ich jetzt den Biskuit und stürze ihn hier
auf einen Tortenretter; ich habe die Backfolie abgezogen.
Ich finde es auch schön,
dass die Mandelstückchen dann im Ofen einfach so ein bisschen rösten.
Das ist ganz gut. Den Biskuit halbiere ich jetzt mit einer Tortensäge.
Ihr könnt aber auch ein Tortenmesser benutzen.
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich hier den unteren Tortenboden,
wie gesagt, den mit den Mandeln.
Ich lege jetzt noch eine Tortenrandfolie drumherum,
denn ich möchte, dass die Torte richtig perfekt wird
und später genau so perfekt da herauskommt.
Ein bisschen größer – die kann man auch immer wieder verwenden;
kann man danach einfach abwaschen.
Dann einen sauberen Tortenring.
Jetzt aber nicht ganz bis zum Biskuit verschließen;
so ein bisschen Rand lassen,
damit die Sahne da noch ein bisschen drunter kann.
Dann nehme ich jetzt ein bisschen Sahne, etwa die Hälfte.
Das wird jetzt schön verstrichen und, wie gesagt,
gern hier am Rand nach unten streichen, am Biskuit vorbei,
damit es am Ende einfach kein Naked-Cake mehr ist,
sondern der wirklich schön mit Sahne umrandet ist.
Glattstreichen, dann die Erdbeeren verteilen.
Ich zeige euch gleich
– also ich habe jetzt hier die Quarkvanillesahne selbst gemacht,
aber ich zeige euch gleich noch eine Variante mit VanillaFIX.
Da muss man nämlich einfach nur die Creme steifschlagen und fertig.
Dann könnt ihr schauen, ob ihr es so oder so machen wollt.
[Musik]
Jetzt hier die restliche Sahne drauf und schön glattstreichen.
Da kommt jetzt der Biskuitdeckel darauf, perfekt!
Dann kann die Torte erst einmal in den Kühlschrank.
Ich zeige euch kurz,
– ich habe nämlich noch einen zweiten Biskuit zubereitet -,
wie ich die zweite Torte fülle, wie ich die Creme zubereite.
Und dann kommt da noch eine Glasur darauf.
Hier habe ich also meinen zweiten Biskuit.
Daraus entsteht noch eine Torte.
Und zwar gibt es von Decocino VanillaFix.
VanillaFIX ist eine Vanillesauce,
die ihr kalt oder warm verwenden könnt.
Es ist eben nicht nur eine Sauce,
sondern auch eine Tortencreme oder eine Muffin- oder Cupcake-Creme.
Ihr könnt sie nämlich flüssig oder einfach so verwenden, über Eis,
Desserts, Waffeln, z. B. auch zum Servieren von Buchteln
oder ihr könnt sie aufschlagen und das Ganze gekühlt
– ich hatte sie jetzt im Kühlschrank –
aufschlagen und dann als Tortenfüllung, Cupcake-Creme verwenden.
Dann muss einfach nichts mehr dazugegeben werden.
Also diese ist wirklich fix und fertig, gut gekühlt
und kommt jetzt hier in meine Rührschüssel.
Das geht auch mit einem Handrührgerät.
Guckt mal: Wenn sie gekühlt ist,
ist sie auch ein bisschen dickflüssiger,
aber wie gesagt, warm schmeckt sie auch sehr gut.
Ich werde sie jetzt einfach nur aufschlagen,
bis sie schön steif ist und die Torte dann genau so füllen.
[Musik]
Ich finde, das Gute ist, wenn man sie nicht ganz aufbraucht,
also wenn man wirklich nur ein bisschen Sauce haben möchte,
hat man einen Deckel, kann es verschließen
und einfach im Kühlschrank aufbewahren.
Ich verwende jetzt hier allerdings die ganze Portion für diese Torte.
[Musik]
Ihr wisst, ich bin ein sparsamer Mensch.
Wenn ich sie ganz aufbrauche,
habe ich so den Tick von meiner Mama und meinem Papa:
Ich muss immer bei jedem Tetra Pak die Ecke wegschneiden.
Immer, auch bei Milch! So, letzter Tropfen.
Jetzt, wie gesagt, einfach ganz kalt aus dem Kühlschrank aufschlagen.
[Musik]
Das Gute bei VanillaFIX ist, man kann es nicht überschlagen,
also nicht wie bei Sahne.
Man merkt dann einfach, dass es fertig ist,
wenn es schön standfest und luftig ist.
[Musik]
Man kann mit VanillaFIX auch Eis zubereiten,
also man kann praktisch diese Masse jetzt einfrieren
und dann ist sie wie ein Vanille-/Softeis. Ist auch sehr gut.
Wie gesagt, als Cupcake, als Sauce (warm oder kalt)…
Also wenn es mal schnell gehen muss
und man jetzt keine Lust hat auf das Abwiegen vieler Zutaten,
dann finde ich es recht cool.
[Musik]
Du hast noch nie probiert, gell?
Magst du einmal probieren? [Josh bejaht]
Ich finde, es hat so eine richtig cremige Konsistenz.
JOSH: Ist wie so ein weiches Kissen.
SALLY: Ja, so smooth. Einfach smooth.
JOSH: Richtig lecker.
SALLY: Hmm! Und man braucht nichts.
Also es bleibt auch schön standfest. Das finde ich gut.
Ich friere es dir noch als Eis ein.
JOSH: Okay.
SALLY: Gut. Dann mache ich jetzt diese noch fertig
und dann geht es gleich direkt weiter zur Erdbeerglasur.
Für die Erdbeerglasur nehme ich 400 g Erdbeeren, 50 g Sahne,
40 g Zucker und 10 g Agar Agar.
Ich habe jetzt hier gedacht, ich nehme Sahne dazu.
Dann schmeckt es bestimmt wie diese Erdbeersahne-Bonbons.
Kennst du die? [Josh bejaht]
Genau, deswegen.
Agar Agar ist einfach ein pflanzliches Geliermittel, statt Gelatine.
Ihr könnt aber natürlich auch Gelatine verwenden,
aber die Zubereitung von Gelatine und Agar Agar ist unterschiedlich.
Agar Agar muss nämlich kochen.
Dass man da den Namen nicht…
Also man hätte es auch… keine Ahnung, wie nennen können:
Gelatine, Agartine gibt es noch, aber Agar Agar finde ich…
Das hört sich irgendwie Gaga an, oder?
Wieso nennt man das so?
Decocino haben das Blatt Vegatine genannt – finde ich cool.
Blatt Vegatine statt Blatt Gelatine, ist auch in Blattform,
aber Agar Agar ist so… naja, egal!
Ich gebe jetzt alle Zutaten hier hinein.
Wenn euch die Erdbeeren süß genug sind,
müsst ihr auch gar kein Zucker dazugeben
- dürft ihr einfach selbst probieren,
aber unsere sind noch ein bisschen säuerlich.
Jetzt alles pürieren.
[Musik]
Jetzt kann ich hier die Masse in einen Topf umfüllen.
Ihr könnt auch direkt alles im Topf pürieren,
aber ich nehme lieber ein bisschen höheres Gefäß,
damit es nicht spritzt.
Jetzt hier aufkochen lassen
und dann muss die Masse 2 Min. lang sprudelnd kochen,
damit die pflanzliche Geliermasse auch wirken kann.
Ich mache das jetzt hier einfach so:
Ich lasse es aufkochen, stelle dann die Uhrzeit am Herd ein
und dann muss ich nicht auf die Uhr achten.
Ich habe sowieso kein. Wenn, dann hätte ich ein Handy.
Ich hatte noch nie eine Armbanduhr.
Fun Fact über Sally.
[Musik]
Jetzt ist die Masse fertiggekocht.
Was ich auf jeden Fall immer machen würde,
egal, ob mit Gelatine oder Agar Agar:
immer eine Gelierprobe,
d.h., ein kleines bisschen auf den Teller,
dann in den Kühlschrank stellen.
Wenn es innerhalb von 1-2 Min. kalt und fest ist,
dann ist es perfekt und ich kann es weiterverwenden. Ansonsten müsste
man noch einmal Geliermasse dazu geben.
Ich fülle es hier jetzt kurz um, denn jetzt ist es noch zu heiß,
also so kann ich es jetzt nicht auf die Torte gießen.
Da schmilzt die komplette Sahne darunter weg. Das wäre fatal!
Um das Ganze jetzt noch einmal luftiger zu bekommen,
weil es gibt einen Unterschied zwischen Gelatine und Agar Agar:
Zum einen ist das eine tierisch, das andere pflanzlich,
zum anderen ist es die Eigenschaft:
Gelatine macht das Ganze Mousse-ähnlicher, luftiger und lockerer.
Agar Agar ist ein bisschen fester, wie Gummibärchen,
aber man kann dem entgegenwirken,
indem man die fertige Masse dann einfach noch einmal püriert
und locker aufschlägt.
Dann ist es da eben auch so,
dass es einfach nicht geleeartig ist, sondern wirklich auch luftig.
[Musik]
Das lasse ich jetzt hier so ein bisschen lauwarm abkühlen
und kann dann gleich auf die Torte gießen,
aber nicht zu lange stehen lassen.
Agar Agar wird nämlich schneller fest als Gelatine.
Nicht zu lange warten!
Guckt mal, so sieht jetzt die Gelierprobe aus.
Also wirklich gut, schön fest geworden.
D.h., die Masse kann jetzt schnell auf die Torte
und dann in den Kühlschrank.
Wenn man das dreht, dann verteilt sie sich auch direkt.
Dann muss man gar nicht streichen.
Dann ein bisschen klopfen.
Zack.
Jetzt kommt sie in den Kühlschrank.
Dann habe ich ja noch die Sahne für die Dekoration
und schneide noch ein paar Erdbeeren auf. Dann ist die Torte fertig.
[Musik]
[Flüstert] Uiuiuiuiiii, uiuiuiuiii.
So, das mache ich gleich weg.
Jetzt erst einmal hier die halbierten Erdbeeren.
Ach, ich mache das gleich mit Sahnetupfern.
[Lacht] Ist jetzt nicht passiert!
[Verdutztes Lachen] Echt jetzt?!
Was ist mit Sally passiert?! Warum ist sie so gechillt?
Ich glaube, ich mache das jetzt so
und dann lege ich eine Erdbeere darauf… und hier.
So wird es doch schön, oder?
[Musik]
So, jetzt kurz umgesetzt.
Ihr könnt den Ring auch noch dran lassen und dann umsetzen.
Dann könnt ihr sie nämlich, wenn ihr den jetzt dran hättet
und sie ist z.B. nicht ganz mittig,
mit dem Ring noch so ein bisschen verschieben.
Dann passiert der Torte nichts.
Jetzt nehme ich hier die Folie weg.
Die Folie ist immer gut, vor allem,
wenn man etwas mit Agar Agar oder mit Gelatine oben macht.
Dann ist da der Rand einfach perfekt.
Für den Rand hier unten nehme ich mir jetzt hier ein bisschen Creme
und eine Palette, streiche es noch ein bisschen glatt.
Da kommen dann noch ein paar Mandeln dran.
Die habe ich vorher geröstet,
damit sie praktisch die gleiche Farbe haben wie die Mandeln am Boden.
Dann ist die Torte fertig.
[Musik]
Jetzt kann ich die Torte anschneiden. Heute darf Sarah probiert.
Sie probiert so selten. [Beide lachen]
SARAH: Soll ich mich vorstellen? [Sally lacht]
SALLY: Sollen wir mal einen Zusammenschnitt machen aus „Sarah probiert!“?
BEIDE: Hmm! Hmm!
SALLY: Das nachfolgende Video verzögert sich um…
SARAH: Kann ich auch Bilder von Cataleya verwenden?
SALLY: Ja, weil Cataleya ist die schönste Katze der Welt.
SARAH: Das Geld gebe ich dir später. [Sally stimmt zu]
Oh, das sieht aber süß aus.
SALLY: Gell? Schon süß!
SARAH: Was genau ist das? Erdbeertorte?
SALLY: Bananen… [Beide lachen]
Erdbeertorte!
SARAH: Nein, aber ist das ein Rührteigboden?
SALLY: Biskuit. [Lacht]
SARAH: Fast.
[Sally flüstert ihr leise zu]
Und eine Quarksahnecreme? [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Wahnsinn!
SARAH: Und das obendrauf ist?
SALLY: Das obendrauf ist ein Erdbeerfruchtspiegel.
SARAH: Das riecht schon nach Fruchtzwerge. Ich rieche es schon.
SALLY: Ja! Wenn es der Murat probiert hätte, dann hätte er auch gesagt:
„Das schmeckt nach Fruchtzwerge!“
Und zwar wollte ich, dass es schmeckt…
Ja, jetzt dreht sie sich um,
weil ihr dann immer darunter schreibt, wie wir essen.
Deswegen dreht sie sich von der Kamera weg.
SARAH: Ihr seid schuld!
SALLY: Ihr seid schuld! Deswegen fragen sie mich immer:
„Warum will die Sally nicht vor der Kamera probieren? Was tut sie so?“
Genau deswegen, weil ich dann Screenshots von euch bekomme.
SARAH: Hast du Screenshots von mir bekommen?
SALLY: Nein, ich habe selbst welche gemacht… Nein! [Beide lachen]
SARAH: Das ist okay.
SALLY: Mmh!!
SARAH: Schmeckt echt wie Fruchtzwerge. [Sally stimmt zu]
Muss ich ehrlich sagen. Sehr lecker!
SALLY: Wie diese Sahne-Bonbons.
Oh, echt wie Fruchtzwerge! Original! Murat wäre begeistert.
SARAH: Er wollte nicht.
SALLY: Er wollte nicht. Ich habe ihn gefragt, „Möchtest du probieren?“.
Dann hat er gesagt, „Nein, ich bin heute so kaputt!“.
SARAH: Ich bin zweite Wahl.
SALLY: Nein, bist du nicht, aber ich musste ihn fragen – er saß da.
SARAH: Stimmt, sonst wäre er eifersüchtig.
SALLY: Ja. Wenn ich jetzt erst dich gefragt hätte, dann hätte er gesagt:
„Immer fragst du die Sarah zuerst!“
SARAH: Heieieiii.
SALLY: Ach, ist das eine leckere Torte!
SARAH: Sehr sommerlich.
SALLY: Und einfach zu machen, also der Biskuit geht schnell,
die Quarksahnecreme geht schnell.
Oh warte, ich lasse dich einmal noch kurz etwas probieren.
SARAH: Ah, die gleiche! [Beide lachen]
SALLY: Die Quarksahnecreme ist schnell gemacht, ja!
Aber ich habe noch eine Torte mit VanillaFIX gemacht.
SARAH: Ich wollte gerade sagen, das sieht gelber / vanilliger aus.
SALLY: Genau, vanilliger. Ich dachte mir, ich lasse dich einmal probieren.
SARAH: Darf ich jetzt ehrlich sagen, was mir besser gefällt?
SALLY: Ja. Du musst ja auch nicht sagen, ob besser oder schlechter
- einfach nur ob und wie es dir schmeckt.
SALLY: Ich glaube, diese hier ist cremiger. Das sieht man schon.
[Beide lachen]
SARAH: Diese Torte finde ich cremiger,
aber für die Torte an sich finde ich es sommerlicher,
wenn es ohne Vanille ist, aber schmeckt trotzdem sehr gut.
SALLY: Ich finde auch die Creme gut, aber ihr kennt mich ja auch.
Ich bereite lieber alles selbst zu.
Dennoch wollte ich es euch vorstellen und zeigen,
weil es eine coole Alternative ist.
Man kann wirklich alles daraus herstellen.
SARAH: Geht es nicht sogar damit schneller? Wahrscheinlich schon, oder?
SALLY: Sie ist sehr schnell einfach steifgeschlagen und fertig,
aber ich bin der Quarksahne-Typ.
Von daher probiert es einfach aus. Ihr könnt ja die Creme zubereiten,
die ihr möchtet. Ich wünsche euch viel Spaß dabei.
Sarah macht jetzt noch wunderschöne Fotos vom Anschnitt.
[Sarah lacht]
Tschüss!
SARAH: Wenn nicht alles umfällt…
Also das ist das beste Teil hier. [Beide lachen]
SALLY: Gönn dir! Tschüss.
SARAH: Schneidest du mir das noch runter? [Sally bejaht]
[Lacht] Richtig lost hier.
[Musik]